[Musik]
ratspräsidentschaft das bedeutet macht
und einfluss in brüssel bei jedem thema
in brüssel wird von einer corona
präsidentschaft gesprochen und die
deutschen werden daran gemessen werden
ob sie es hinkriegen diesen gigantischen
hilfstopf zu verhandeln und den
siebenjährigen eu haushalt doch da geht
es ja um gemeinsame schulden deutschland
war da immer dagegen und jetzt plötzlich
in zeiten corona ist deutschland dafür
ja es ist nur so dass wir in irgendeiner
weise sind sicherstellen müssen dass in
allen europäischen ländern der
wirtschaftsmotor wieder in gang kommt
und die länder um die es geht die haben
bereits eine sind überfluss nämlich
schulden wenn es um so viel geld gibt
davon dürften auch unterschiedliche
positionen ausgesprochen werden
aber ich teile die einschätzung dass
europa zum erfolg verpflichtet ist und
die deutsche gesellschaft zum erfolg
verpflichtet ist ein scheitern dieses
wiederaufbau plant kann sich europa
nicht leisten
aus der mitte berlins werden in den
nächsten sechs monaten die geschicke
europas gelenkt die herausforderungen
sind riesig in zeiten von corona ist es
wirklich eine historische aufgabe für
die bundesregierung die
ratspräsidentschaft wird corona
präsidentschaft nicht nur technisch auch
politisch hat corona alles verändert
berlin muss nun europas größte krise
managen über milliarden- verhandeln die
eu vor der spaltung bewahren die
erwartungen gewaltig da soll ein großer
wiederaufbau vor helfen wir können uns
mal die zahlen noch mal angucken
[Musik]
das ist zumindest der vorschlag der
eu-kommission und das herr altmaier muss
nun verhandelt werden
wie zuversichtlich sind sie sehen dass
das alles vielleicht noch im juli in
trockenen tüchern ist ja wir brauchen
einen aufschwung wir brauchen wachstum
damit wir unsere ehrgeizigen klimaziele
unsere ziele in der sozialen sicherheit
im umweltschutz realisieren können es
wird irgendwas volumen gehe wie viel
witz insgesamt geben an geld das auf den
tisch gelegt mit und natürlich auf
welche art und weise kann dieses geld in
anspruch genommen werden diese frage
zuschüsse oder kredite aber unser ziel
ist es zugegebenermaßen das jetzt im
juli zu lösen das ist nicht so einfach
aber man wird schlapp wir gehen davon
aus dass ist klappt das zweite mega
thema eu haushalt auch hier ist einigung
pflicht im halbstundentakt geben sich
europas botschafter im büro der
deutschen die klinke in die hand noch
nie wurden in der eu solche
milliarden-summen verhandelt wie jetzt
wir diskutieren darüber dass bei dem
haushalt den wir ausstellen müssen der
so genannte mehrjährige finanzrahmen für
die nächsten sieben jahre der
europäischen union dass der in
verbindung mit der rechtsstaatlichkeit
geführt werden muss wenn ich mir
anschaue wie die diskussion in den
letzten jahren dazu geführt wurde das
thema ist ja schon länger präsent
dadurch dass am schluss man
wahrscheinlich den weg gehen muss den
geldhahn zuzudrehen und das eher
geeignet ist den ein oder anderen zu
bewegen auf den pfad der tugend
zurückzukehren
und dann wäre da noch der branche zu
managen ein großprojekt das fast zur
randnotiz wurde
seit ende januar ist großbritannien
heraus aus der eu aber jetzt muss einen
handelsvertrag her oder auch nicht je
nachdem was boris johnson in london
zuvor hatte mitte juni macht das erste
treffen seit der korona krise auf
höchster ebene den weg frei für die
aktuelle verhandlungsrunde zwischen
london und brüssel wo klar ist was wir
erreichen wollen so weit sind wir nicht
voneinander entfernt in den
verhandlungen braucht es nur ein wenig
doch bei den haupt knackpunkten gibt es
bislang kaum fortschritte
erstens großbritannien will nicht mehr
dass eu troller wie bislang in
britischen hoheitsgewässern ihre netze
auswerfen dürfen zweitens brüssel
fordert dass london die
arbeits und sozialstandards der eu
übernimmt und drittens will brüssel dass
der bei den black city das verhasste
europäische gerichtshof auch in zukunft
bei streitigkeiten urteilt der breccia
sie waren immer gegen den br- exit wie
ist groß ist ihre angst jetzt dass es
dazu kommt dass großbritannien wirklich
kein handelsvertrag mit der eu
abschließen wird es ist sehr groß und
zwar richtig dass das das absichtliche
ziel von johnson und seiner regierung
ist und sie hoffen den wirtschaftlichen
sozialen schaden von brad pitt und den
trümmerhaufen vom kobe zu verstecken das
fragen sich in europa viele warum baus
johnston so hart verhandelt ob das nur
bluff ist oder ob es wie sie sagen
wirklich auf einen austritt ohne
handelsabkommen herauskommen das was ist
denn seine strategie und warum sollte er
das wollen werde ich seine strategie
strategie wusste dann wäre ich sehr
weise also jemand ihn nie wirklich
einschätzen und wir haben uns bei den
menschen in europa mal umgehört was sie
davon halten dass jetzt die deutschen am
ruder sind
da gibt es keine änderung außer sagen
wir mal politische werbung aber wenn wir
alle in der kette sind dann muss jeder
einmal der hausherr sein
ich habe kein beleg dafür aber es kommt
mir vor dass es eine wichtige nation ist
ich stelle mir vor wie in deutschland
redet hört man zu es fühlt sich an als
stünde dahinter eine autorität
ich habe angst dass die europäer allen
voran die franzosen nur auf sich schauen
und angst haben dass deutschland
voranschreitet in deutschland läuft es
gut auch wirtschaftlich und sogar die
korona krise haben sie gut überstanden
während das hier ein drama eine starke
meinung aus frankreich und dazu wollen
wir natürlich die französische botschaft
verrinnen befragen man hat das gefühl
durch die korona krise arbeiten makro
und merkel wieder ein bisschen enger
zusammen brauchte es erst diese große
krise dafür
nein auf keinen fall präsident marc und
bundeskanzlerin merkel haben nie
aufgehört zusammen eng
zusammenzuarbeiten
und wenn der plan der am 18 mai
angekündigt wurde natürlich eine phase
der intensiven arbeit benötigte das ist
auch das ergebnis von einer engen
zusammenarbeit seit drei jahren
eigentlich jetzt kommen wir zu einem
mann der nicht nur hoch erfolgreiche
bücher schreibt wie schuld wie strafe
die verbrechen sondern der sich auch
gedanken macht um gott und die welt und
vor allem auch um europa ferdinand von
schirach bestsellerautor und jurist sie
fordern diese kroner krise zu nutzen und
fordern eine europäische verfassung was
muss man sich darunter vorstellen
na ja wir haben ja das ist das wirklich
neue an dieser krone diese wir haben
plötzlich gelernt dass wir alles tun
können wenn wir das wollen dass die
staaten bereit sind alle möglichen dinge
über den haufen zu schmeißen die noch
vor zwei wochen
felsenfest da standen was könnte denn
drin stehen in so einer europäischen
verfassung und was würde sie verändern
also das subtropische wäre laute sachen
dort reinzuschreiben die wir uns im
moment nicht vorstellen können zum
beispiel dass jeder mensch das alleinige
recht über seine daten hat dass jeder
mensch einen anspruch hat auf eine
intakte umwelt oder das weltweit also
von allem was von uns ausgeht immer die
menschenrechte vor wirtschaftlichen
überlegungen stehen sollten das sind zum
beispiel drei solcher forderungen die
utopisch werden dass ihnen heute jeder
politiker sagen würde das können wir
nicht machen
[Musik]